so I'm just breaking up the eggs have
you ever seen hey guys it's Inka so I am
back this time to make another cake from
a different part of the world and this
time I am making martabak monies from
Indonesia a lot of you have challenged
me to make this on Instagram one of my
good friends Stephanie also challenged
me to do this he's also here today and
it will be taste
[Music]
I'm Stephanie the friends my niece means
sweet
Oh your money so truth you're sweet I
love that we like roll our arse
so it's like Madoff above my knees oh no
I cannot rule my heart mark the bunk
that's actually very lot of money smart
about money there's two types there's
the sweet one and the salty one so this
one's about money's and mark them oh I
see I see me and salty but the sweet one
yo so I asked her what she wanted on her
mark the buckle bunnies and she said
chocolate sprinkles Nutella cheese
condensed milk I just give you like what
the usual menu of like Oh Martha Buck
place would have usually they like do it
like a pizza so it's like a Nutella
section of the cheese section so today
we're going all out wall out I did a lot
of research and I tested a lot of
recipes you did I did alright and this
is great I'm nervous
yah yah yah yah that's not done oh no
I'm tearing it apart ruined it
this operation has failed okay
well you ready yes here is up we're
ready to go I feel like you're ready a
party always gonna try sifting yeah
Wow yeah cuz you gotta also sift through
the haters labor makes it I don't even
think that makes sense first start off
with bread flour bread flours did your
son do my thing yeah all right
Valentine's Day I always make stuff for
my best friends like I made whoopie pies
last year I wasn't very good and I had a
mental breakdown but the efforts there
it's a great time today well I can't
promise anything we are going to put in
the salt doing a cracker there's gonna
be a good day a bad day
let's see I'm just have you ever seen
street food do this like making the
batter because it's a very like fast
street food they do their thing and then
like you turn back and it's like done
people out here are like just always
ready for you need me a man like that I
am so different if I saw somebody add
like vanilla powder mmm
it is good but it's like you shouldn't
have it by itself I mean I've done that
no well as a child but you know it
smells good so you assume it tastes good
too I'm gonna combine these okay good
shoe girl doing your thing I should make
you do this so you can call it your own
it's our own special it's in kinda nice
oh it's stinkers because I should oh
that's the better I see you know how
it's like it just looks very like I'm on
the right track you are you are what
we're gonna do now is resting it yeah
like that I assume you just like rest
things that have yeast in them East is
for it to rise right this is just for it
to relax whoa I need that gonna grab
and chilies for an hour what should we
do well I got two new songs out girl
it's called do you love me and touch do
you love me let me let me let me let me
yeah yeah do you love me love me love me
love me not
alright be right back okay looks the
exact same it's like kind of like you
know viscous viscous now we're gonna add
in the baking soda which is what makes
it rise do a little mixing that's how
you make cloudy water and now we're
gonna put that in that's a cool way to
incorporate baking soda people like they
accidentally bite into a bunch of baking
soda they don't like mix it well enough
and by people I mean me so good hack
thank you
[Music]
okay oh wow yeah yeah what I think makes
the Martha book is the fact that it's
like bubbling everywhere and so there's
like strands of like air and yes and
that's why that you get the honeycomb
texture yes that was the most important
thing I was trying so hard to get that
honeycomb texture you were talking about
now we wait for the blaze okay so you
come here often
do you like weather see those bubbles
please don't burn please don't burn
I tested but like you know sometimes
food is just has its own like
personality exactly
sometimes it's sassy you're gonna give
this like seven minutes let me clear
this up okay you guys so cute she's very
lovable which is why I watched a lot of
your videos so people who watch believe
in yourself one day you too can make a
video with Inka what is going on here is
for you to check post trifle really I
know I know I was saying this earlier
when I get goosebumps that's when I know
I need to put the lid on
I have Nutella mhm what you want this is
what my favorite topping is this is like
oh gee that's like we'll all be people
always been like chocolate and then we
have cheese cheese yes you have a lot of
butter for their appearance and we have
condensed milk because staple it goes
well with everything it does your first
bite it should just be like a burst of
oil and butter in your mouth and you're
like oh my god but then like the flavor
of the market uh becomes and it's like
the chocolate starts melting in your
mouth so he's just like huh very chewy
and then the crust is a bit like crispy
absolutely adds like one
pretty good pretty good
this is the hardest part because the pan
is like I'm sweating I'm sweating okay
all right okay
you are my customer okay what you want
okay hello sir good morning thank you I
would like it to be spread butter
everywhere that grandma has to like kind
of like go through the holes right so
that when you bite it it like very
greasy so good it's a greased lightning
girl okay right okay let's start with
the chocolate one looks really good oh
man I'm a big boy yeah so beautiful this
is more extra than extra is extra with
mores we put the cheese right I guess is
like an Americanized version of the
usual cheese we use yeah that's it a
little drizzle drizzle on top the
hawkers they poke the holes and yeah a
little thing we would oh Jesus
all right folding oh my god the melted
it's a little extra yes all right that
is the one I'm talking about little like
stringy and then what's important is the
Indonesian way is you cut it in squares
cut it in squares directly
[Music]
a little taste test I usually take a
side PC okay Cheers
okay well you hear that sound did you
hear that show I remind you of it yeah
a lot it was really good I'm like really
emotional it's really good
I've never had this before so I don't
know sorry I shouldn't talk my mouth I
was going off of like fluffy pancake and
like indulgent greasiness I'm getting
that so you like it I like it it's
really good I need to go to any did a
good job yeah when you were a ninja I
got your guide I want to see Stephanie
make her own Martha buck money's at home
I kind of want to really don't like
surprise my friend thanks you guys for
watching let me know again if there's
any other cake or pancake pastry that
you want to see me make in the kitchen
leave a comment below and see you guys
next time
you